l'homme est à terre est-ce que tu veux
l'enfoncer encore plus c'est ça que tu
veux moi je dis non c'est tout moi j'ai
pas envie de voir ça
[Applaudissements]
quelques années tu as 12 ans exactement
tu as 12 ans tu es en vacances c'est ça
et on sait pas comment tu as l'idée de
créer un compte Twitter pas comme les
autres c'est quoi exactement en fait je
m'ennuie en vacances j'ai 12 ans donc le
premier réflexe pour un enfant de cet
âge-là c'est d'aller voir sur Twitter si
jamais crashman un compte non
parce qu'en fait non plus sérieusement
en fait et je m'ennuie complètement et à
l'époque il y a beaucoup de comptes
parodieches de plein de de plein
d'animateurs bien sûr d'accord et je me
suis bah vas-y je vais partir sur
Jean-Luc Reichmann mais par contre ce
qui est important de préciser c'est que
dès le début la première seconde de mon
compte est créé il y a écrit dans ma
biographie compte parodique
ma volonté c'est à aucun moment ma
volonté c'est de me faire passer pour
lui vraiment à 100% comme de l'usure
passion j'en voyais pas compte parodique
tout de suite donc ils ont pas mal les
gens moi en fait j'étais stupéfé parce
que même à l'époque je me dis ferme-moi
à 12 ans je vois un compte je vois
Jean-Luc Reichmann qui dit qui est en
train de préparer une paella et qu'il
est dévasté parce qu'il avait tombé au
sol je commence quand même à tilter que
c'est pas forcément le vrai compte mais
ça peut ça peut passer je te jure ouais
ouais bah ça peut passer et le fait que
c'est très bien passé j'avais même
j'ai pris à peu près 12 13000 abonnés je
pense dans la soirée j'ai fait un tweet
j'avais dit bonjour à tous Voilà je vous
révèle la vérité je suis un enfant de 13
ans et demi qui qui voilà juste créer ce
compte ça prend une ampleur de fou mais
voilà je ne suis pas Jean-Luc Reichmann
je suis un enfant de 13 ans et demi je
me suis dit voilà c'est terminé et là
tout le monde ne répond mais quand je
dis tout le monde c'est une quarantaine
de personnes mais non Jean-Luc ne vous
rabaissez pas vous n'êtes pas un enfant
de 13 ans et demi
qui passe et je gagne 14000 abonnés je
me dis bon c'est parti là je continue on
m'a proposé de faire les 12 coups de
midi et moi j'ai directement pensé à ce
qui s'était passé justement on va
prendre l'émission enfin à part ce qui
s'était passé avant avec mon compte
twitter je me suis dit c'est trop
marrant il faut que je le fasse et du
coup je participe à l'émission
évidemment il ne sait pas que c'est moi
et d'ailleurs il me pose une question
sur les réseaux sociaux il demande
est-ce que je suis branché sur les
réseaux et à ce moment-là je réponds
énormément avec un sourire mais
jusqu'aux oreilles parce que au fond de
moi oui lui il ne sait pas pourquoi je
suis très branché sur les réseaux mais
moi je sais pourquoi
on est dans la merde
simplement et moi je pourrais pas
travailler deux ans de plus c'est pas
possible là actuellement j'ai 47 ans je
me lève les doigts ils sont paralysés le
matin parce que vous savez on pince
d'accord on a les coudes on a des
fourmis les genoux
les les chevilles la pénibilité chez
nous elle est juste elle est juste
importante très importante dans beaucoup
de métiers mais là je parle du mien pour
montrer la situation catastrophique à
Paris regardez voilà regardez regardez
regardez dans le 12e arrondissement
aussi pour mettre la vidéo regardez ça
permet de voir en plus
ça me choque mais c'est notre seul moyen
de pression qui promène dans Paris
on a fait pour les regards scène
musicale
avec cette réforme on veut nous vendre
de la merde ben nous on va laisser la
merde sur le trottoir en fait simplement
qu'est-ce qui peut là parce que là on va
en parler dans un instant mais c'est
catastrophique là j'ai juste une
question tous les arrondissements à
Paris n'ont pas le même sort les
arrondissements qui sont avec un des
éboueurs privés
c'est la même que pour la vôtre pourquoi
ils sont pas
aussi pour eux
au niveau financier c'est compliqué moi
j'ai fait trois jours de grève j'ai 225
€ de moins sur mon salaire et je vais
continuer je trouverai des aides peu
importe mais ce qui arrive plus tard
c'est ça le plus important on se bat
pour nous mais pas pour nous pour nos
enfants pour l'avenir de notre pays
voilà c'est l'avenir de notre pays
quelle est la solution pourquoi la mer
la mer ne réagit pas Anne Hidalgo
nous ce qu'on
demande l'opposition avec Rachida Dati
c'est qu'on demande un service minimum
pourquoi parce que on respecte le droit
de grève mais à Paris du fait d'une
situation qui est complètement dégradée
déjà en temps normal en matière de
propreté ça crée des problèmes de
sécurité ça crée des problèmes de santé
publique si vous voulez quand vous
faites une opération ponctuelle dans une
ville qui est propre qui bien entretenu
il y a pas de problème enfin la rigueur
c'est compliqué mais on peut l'accepter
mais quand vous le faites dans une ville
où vous avez déjà deux fois plus de
règles d'habitants ça donne beaucoup de
monde dans la rue en ce moment Paris se
vide les classes sont fermées parce
qu'il y a plus d'enfants les gens
quittent pareil comme vous dites à un
moment on n'a jamais vu ça c'est la
capitale de la France c'est quand même
la capitale de la France où personne ne
veut y habiter normalement tout le monde
voudrait y habiter tout le monde
à chaque fois elle s'en satisfaits elle
est Lude moi je vais vous dire un autre
elle a c'est quand même elle a fait
campagnes en 2020 en disant je vais
doubler le budget propreté pour que
Paris soit propre non mais c'était pour
se nettoyer elle
achetait deux fois plus de Tahiti donc
tout le monde vraiment d'oubli enfin je
veux dire c'est pas respecter les
électeurs de faire ça
j'aime pas qu'on tire sur les gens à
terre il est déjà pas bien en ce moment
je n'oublie pas les victimes et
évidemment bien sûr petit bébé de 40 oui
il avait 40 minutes en fait
j'aime pas la la Ligue j'aime pas la
curé j'aime pas le lynchage tu connais
la règle des trois ailes dans le métier
tu lèches tu lâches et tu lâches et
aujourd'hui on est en plein lâchage
médiatique donc c'est pas à nous à juger
moi je suis pas juge il y a des
magistrats pour ça même dit que tu avais
limite envie de Lily quoi de le sortir
de là j'ai pas compris tu as même dit
que tu avais limite envie de l'aider de
le sortir de là il est tellement il est
mal tellement on le linge que bon c'est
vrai qu'au bout d'un moment bon ça
suffit ça va ça me choque parce que
quand vous dites il est mort je suis
désolé mais il y a un côté quel dommage
que les médias parlent de l'affaire quel
dommage que Pierre Palmade ne soit pas
soutenu il a pris une voiture en ayant
consommé
mais oui mais oui mais il est mort non
il est pas mort son avocate fait des
démarches etc il aura le droit à un
procès
de regretter qu'il soit mort
immédiatement je suis désolé je suis
désolé je ne sais pas du tout l'homme
est à terre ah oui est-ce que tu veux
l'enfoncer encore plus et ça que tu veux
moi je dis non c'est tout moi j'ai pas
envie de ça envie de voir ça fracasser
un mec qui déjà voilà est mort et déjà
mort voilà c'est un peu tout moche après
je comprends que ça révolte beaucoup de
gens parce qu'effectivement ils
comprennent pas
dès que tu dis un mot en revanche
c'est épouvantable et moi par contre je
trouve pas qu'on en fasse trop on est
très factuel il y a un débat en plus
judiciaire sur le traitement de
l'affaire tout le monde n'est pas l'ami
de Pierre Palmade moi que ses amis ils
défendent ça me choque pas en revanche
qu'on en parle à la télé c'est normal
pardon bien sûr tu dis c'est factuel je
suis pas d'accord avec toi ce qu'il a
fait encore une fois c'est atroce quand
on parle de sa sexualité de ce qui fait
ses nuits de kiriki couche on va au-delà
du tout le Ken sec c'est le point de
départ
quand on décrit ce qui fait dans sa vie
sexuelle à lui qui se tape un mec de
microbes excuse-moi c'est son problème
donc on est effectivement je suis assez
d'accord il y a aussi une feuille de
voilà ça aussi un petit peu débordé de
voilà l'homosexualité de voilà mais oui
bien sûr mais arrête bien sûr que oui
tous les détails de sa vie
tous les détails de sa vie qui sortent
servent le propos la drogue ça sert le
propos lequel sexe c'est le point de
départ d'accident pardon mais on a un
peu éclipsé la pédoporno pornographie
pour la car il a été certes innocenté
bah il y a rien pardon il y a qu'on a
parlé de l'existence d'une vidéo où il
regarde une vidéo pas de pornographique
en disant ça va c'est OK
qui regarde des vidéos P2
pornographiques donc voilà donc tous ces
détails qui sont révélés par la presse
je suis désolé il servent la faire il
pose des questions de société et on ne
s'acharne pas sur pierre pas mal et moi
ce qui me choque c'est pas le traitement
médiatique de maintenant c'est le
traitement médiatique d'avant en fait on
avait ce mec qui se balader sur des
plateaux encore une fois on a revu une
archive il y a quelques années où il
disait au calme voilà moi je me défonce
je fais des soirées je fais du Ken sexe
ils sont cachés pas sur les réseaux
sociaux sur les récits de rencontre il
écrivait le premier message qu'il
écrivait qu'aime sexe voilà donc ça
c'était normal c'était cool parce que
c'est une célébrité parce que c'est une
star pour dire rien
évidemment donc au contraire le
traitement médiatique de maintenant il
rectifie et il dit aux gens que la
drogue non c'est pas cool c'est pas
parce qu'on a une star qu'on a le droit
de se défoncer et de se et de faire
n'importe quoi la drogue c'est de la
merde ça tue ceux qui en prennent et ça
tue ceux qui croisent le chemin de ceux
qui en prennent
et des spécialistes s'inquiètent de ce
phénomène c'est le concours de baffe
[Applaudissements]
c'est surtout pas interdire il faut
codifier ça va rentrer dans l'UFC ça va
devenir un sport qui va émerger comme le
MMA
tu sais que je pense ça va être un
énorme bien sûr
arrêter avec sa carton aux États-Unis
depuis quand les États-Unis c'est le
c'est la référence au ce qui concerne en
matière de MMA ça explose c'est pas pour
autant que c'est bien on perd des
dizaines de centaines d'euros à chaque
fois voilà c'est compliqué comme la boxe
c'est beau ça c'est moche en fait c'est
une sorte de noblesse
[Musique]
je suis non voyant c'est un chien guide
vous êtes au milieu de le prendre
monsieur
alors elle est incroyable cette histoire
anthony est avec nous et son chien nepia
il est 8h45 lorsque vous commandez un
VTC sur la plateforme uber vous le
faites souvent tous les matins parce que
j'emmène ma fille à l'école et puis
également le soir puisque je la récupère
vous êtes vous êtes que avec napia ce
matin là je suis avec nepia je suis avec
ma fille ça de quatre ans ainsi que sa
grand-mère que je dois dormir à la
maison et que je dois déposer chez elle
vous signalez avant uber ou bien vous le
faites sur l'appli non que je suis non
voyant donc vous avez de la chance
il y a tellement de refus que je lui
donne si je dis ça la liberté de refuser
normalement légalement il est obligé
d'accepter le chien j'ai absolument il y
a la loi qui autorise à prendre les
transports sinon il y a une amende de
450 euros c'est prévu dans la loi il n'a
pas le droit de refuser et lui du coup
je me dis oui mais le chien va dans le
coffre pas de problème donc je vais vers
le coffre on ouvre le coffre il décale
en sac je fais mon ténépia et là il
commence à me toucher
à côté de ça j'ai ma petite fille de 4
ans qui regarde ça c'est un obsession
elle est elle est témoin de ça parce que
ma fille elle est en retard à l'école
là je sais qu'il y a ma fille qui est
toujours là qui regarde je me dis
surtout reste calme reste digne et je me
dis elle a déjà quelqu'un qui est en
train durer sur son papa quelqu'un qui
est en train d'hurler sur son chien qui
est en train de maltraiter probablement
son chien donc ne rajoute pas de la
violence à la violence enfin il veut
appeler la police il veut porter plainte
il est persuadé que c'est moi qui l'ai
agressé
il faut savoir que ce monsieur a porté
plainte contre moi pour violence vous
avez porté plaindre aussi je vais porter
plainte bien sûr au départ vous allez
chercher vous savez pas qu'il y a un
chien
oui moi je savais pas parce que c'est
l'application je mets pas les animaux
enfin je suis allergique
vous vous dites quoi moi je pense pas
parce que c'est de la Fabrique
c'est ça les moi je suis choqué que je
reviens avec des téléphones et en train
de filmer et après il est présenté qui
était avec les timel vaillant voilà je
suis choqué comment il est en train de
filmer vous voulez pas le prendre avec
le chien pourquoi non moi je suis
allergique c'est parce que
c'est pas toi qui
décide
tu veux pas le chien de la voiture
d'accord
il était déconnecté et je vous rappelle
qu'il est présumé innocent donc il fait
la justice le mal qui fait sur tous les
autres VTC qui font bien leur boulot
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
style que 49 alinéa 3 de la Constitution
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement mais sur le fond il faut
s'attendre à des jours et des semaines
explosives parce que là le gouvernement
en méprisant le l'assemblée qui est en
fait l'assemblée qui la représentation
du peuple donc en fait elle crache pas
elle crache sa figure c'était un mot un
peu excessif en tout cas elle marche sur
les droits de du peuple et du coup elle
impose quelque chose d'un passage en
force qui n'est pas le premier est-ce
que faut quand même rappeler que c'est
la 11e fois qu'elle fait passer le 49,3
qu'elle utilise de 49-3 pour faire voter
une loi c'est autant que durant les 25
dernières années regardez la suite des
ces manifestations il y en a qui ont mis
à partir des mannequins à l'effigie
d'Emmanuel Macron et du gouvernement qui
leur ont mis le feu les images sont
incroyables c'est l'image qui a le plus
aujourd'hui
c'est l'image du jour on va pas se
mentir c'est vraiment après l'annonce du
49-3 c'est l'image du jour c'est
incroyable cette image Gilles c'est fou
c'est un symbole qui pour moi est
dévastateur je vous le dis franchement
quel que soit la cause quel que soit la
sympathique on puisse avoir pour les
grévistes on ne peut pas brûler des
mannequins à l'effigie de personnes
reconnaissable après moi je suis
d'accord avec Jean-Mi je suis très
pessimiste je pense qu'il y a une telle
colère une telle exaspération une telle
rage que finalement les mouvements
sociaux c'était un peu tassé et là ce
49,3 comme ça un peu qui vient à la
barbe de tout le monde je pense que ça
va remettre le feu aux poudres ça va
remettre du carburant dans mes
mouvements sociaux effectivement moi je
pense que ça peut être le chaos il lui
restait des années de mandat il aurait
pu faire ça la dernière année il l'a
fait au plus mauvais moment pour les
Français voilà c'était juste ça c'était
après le PGE alors justement alors il y
a des gens aussi qui lisent c'est que
c'est c'est en fait ils le prennent à
l'envers ils disent je pense qu'il a
fait exprès
en permanence ça c'est un truc très
important
on comprend les grésistes à fond mais
elle a quand même énormément de courage
cette femme en direct regardez je trouve
pas ça actuellement regardez ce qui se
passe actuellement hein voilà c'est en
train de partir en cacahuète à la fin de
compte actuellement à gauche
on a pas mal d'images
en fait je pense que le le peuple est
français on a l'impression qu'on leur
parle pas qu'on leur parle plus et c'est
ça qui l'aimait encore plus dans une
colère qui fait que aujourd'hui ils ont
envie voilà de de rentrer dans un chaos
et c'est vrai que la retraite ça c'est
vraiment c'est c'est le sujet c'est le
sujet le plus touchy pour tous les
gouvernements tous les gouvernements ont
voulu faire la réforme des retraites
jamais personne de la fête parce qu'à
chaque fois c'est extrêmement touché et
aujourd'hui on le voit au jour et quand
on fait une réforme comme ça je pense
que la première chose c'est de discuter
de voilà de d'essayer de l'amener voilà
le mieux possible parce qu'on sait que
derrière ça va amener un chaos qui va
être important quand on voit des mots
qui manifestent pour la retraite par ne
pardonner moi mais enfin voilà moi je
comprends mais 2500 réforme d'ici là
quand ils seront à la retraite donc je
pense que le vrai problème aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il y a une sorte de trop plein
exactement la retraite est un des
facteurs mais en fait il englobe tout
oui on va dire qu'aujourd'hui il y a un
ras-le-bol général et je vous dis il y a
de plus en plus de gens qui travaillent
9h par jour et qui n'arrivent pas à
nourrir leur enfant donc ça c'est un
supportable et là c'est vrai que il faut
rentrer le dialogue français
le secrétaire général de la CFDT qui est
exemplaire de enfin moi je trouve
extraordinaire et lui il aime pas par
exemple ces images là il classe a
décrédient complètement le mouvement
pareil à l'Assemblée nationale la
nupesse là qui chante qui Antonne qui te
fous de la gueule de bord lui dit que
c'est des testables aussi donc je pense
que vous avez raison c'est il faut le
dire voilà
parce que les Français se sont dit qu'on
n'a pas débattu du
sanglier son rôle on n'a pas débattu on
a même pas on a même pas débattu de
l'amendement sur les 64 ans
ce texte là n'est même pas passé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]